former walmart executive and e-commerce
billionaire mark lore wants to build the
world's first woke city from scratch
somewhere in the us we are going to be
the most open the most fair and the most
inclusive city in the world laura said
in a promotional video the city is meant
to take on what lore's view on the
united states the biggest challenge the
rapidly grown wealth gap which he said
is growing going to bring down america
the initial phase of the project
targeted for completion by 2030 would be
built to accommodate 50 000 residents
across 1500 acres at a cost of 25
billion over 40 years the city will
eventually
require 40 400 billion dollars of
funding and funding and grow to house as
many as 5 million people across 150 000
acres if it's so effective why do you
need to be funded
why do you need to be funded to build
this woke city that's what it's going to
look like by the way take a look at that
wow
what a beautiful woke city that is that
needs funding from other taxpayers who
are not woke
so the only way a woke city model works
that it's funded by people who are not
welcome really i love when the uh the 17
year old communist always talks about
how the only reason why cuba was
unsuccessful was because of the evil
embargoes from the united states like
whoa
this this this communist utopia needed
their capitalist neighbor what would you
not making the argument you think you're
making here man
if they said what state this would be in
uh i would imagine oregon next to
portland can you actually go to the
article to see where they're thinking
about city-wise
as long as it's not in florida and texas
if we should be fine we'll just
let's
go i'm i'm looking today it's called
telos
is that a play on tesla
called tulosa telosa from the ancient
greek word
telos meaning highest purpose the
mission tells us to create more
equitable sustainable future that's our
north star we're going to be the most
open okay i read that equitism equitism
equitism
residents and turn on their own homes on
the land and are enriched as home value
increases according to the project site
and after period of hyper growth
residents can buy the land from the
community endowment
okay if you went into the desert where
the land wasn't numbers
and foundation okay we don't know well
folks if you're listening to this
anybody planning on going to this woke
city it sounds like burning man
that's what this sounds what it sounds
like is you're going to get a mortgage
from the city instead of a bank it
sounds exactly like what we have now
except your mortgages to the city
instead of the banks these guys have
lost their mind by the way to do
something like this by the way here's
here's what i'm willing to do why don't
we do this see this hold on real quick
you see that stuff i don't mind like
when they start talking about new york
city you know every rooftop in new york
city should be solar or you should have
plants on it i'm totally okay
there's only one problem i have with
this there's only one problem i have
with this i actually say go do it
matter of fact here's what i think we
ought to do
you go do yours let us go build our own
city let us build our own city you go
build your own let's make it a project
let us go 20 years sure we build our own
city give us 1500 acres you get 1500
acres we get 1500 we get 49 states you
guys get california if communism works
in 20 years i'm actually being dead
serious if we got 1500 acres we got our
own land that we would build they get
their own 1500 acres i couldn't agree
here's the difference here's the
difference there's only one caveat here
one caveat there can be zero funding
from the government zero funding from
taxpayers you do your work city we do
all our own free thinker city let's see
20 years what happens okay let's just
say 20 years what happens
neither can we can do whatever we can do
20 years later let's see what we produce
let's see what you produce city full of
people let's see what kind of people we
produce and let's see what kind of
people are you going to produce
and who ends up recruiting who from
which city your woke city versus the
free thinker city you know there was a
movie that this reminds me of uh one of
my favorite actors is leonardo dicaprio
and i don't know 10 plus years ago he
did a movie called the beach
which was supposed to be like this um
this paradise i think i think it took
place in thailand i want to say
he was googling paradise
and he shows up him and a friend and
another girl and they go to this city
and it says paradise and it's you know
egalitarian and everything's beautiful
and the most
pristine beaches in the world and you're
hunting and killing and finding your own
food and then it takes a very ugly turn
and where human nature yeah human nature
kicks in and um
what's the uh what's the movie where the
the the kids they're all on the island
and they they killed the fat kid because
he
they speak with a conch what was that
movie what was the book uh oh i know
what's talking about you talking about
lord of the flag lord of the flies yeah
very lord of the fly esque type of
situation the bottom line is it starts
off in this
paradise type
uh
story and it looked amazing and by the
end of the movie everyone was freaking
dead and the guys came in and killed
everybody that's what's going to happen
with this woman
the only way communism will ever work
two things have to happen they have to
take over the entire world they have to
have control of all access to
opportunity worldwide and two they have
to do uh set marriages from the time
you're born lottery marriages because
everything literally everything that we
do everything that our species has ever
done has been a competition for ovaries
that is what it is everything from helen
of troy helen of troy decided to go with
a younger better looking pritz and the
king of macedonia said screw that and
brought a million troops over to troy
and 20 years and then it's in the brad
pitt movie orlando broome it's a little
bit of an older book but yeah so yeah i
know it was the movie was called troy i
get it i know it's basically out of the
odyssey
but yeah
robert zemeckis
but listen literally think about it
everything we do why do you work so hard
you work so hard to provide for your
family you why why do you work out i
have been very in very good shape with
abs i have been very very fat i'm
getting back down again do you know why
because there's benefits to being in
better shape you know everything that we
do as men everything we're 90 of us
there's 10 that don't play that game but
90 of men everything that we do is to
attract the other species if you aren't
going to be born six foot nine 275
pounds then you have to figure out a way
warren buffett said it best warren
buffett when he talks about taxes and
why he wants to give back he's like
because i am very very lucky that i grew
up in a time where my intellect allowed
me to
generate wealth because if the only way
i could generate wealth was getting on a
boat and storming the seas i wouldn't
have been very wealthy i'd been very
dead so that's his idea of giving back
right
everything that we do everything
capitalism really is is fair
and by the way yeah good for unforeseen
it is a fair place system to be able to
i'm telling you listen give us 1500
acres i'm telling you right now if we
got a million people
in in a small little country
test it out with us give us for 20 give
us 20 or see what we do
the world would want to live in our
country yeah okay it would be called
america give it but here's the thing
america is no longer america
america unfortunately is going in in a
different direction
the idea is but there are a few things
at the beginning as a case study that
america could have done slightly
differently what do you mean america is
no longer america you can't just say
that and we never lost over no no what
are you talking about america's still
america america is still the greatest
country in the world but america is no
longer the america that the america is
not the america that i came to america
for lots changed last 30 years a lot's
changed the last 30 years changed the
last 18 months yeah a lot's changed this
is a
do you realize i don't know if i don't
know if you really realize this
if i told you 10 years ago
the president's going to say
i'm sick and tired i'm losing patience
with these governors
who are not mandating vaccine and who
are not getting their people to get
vaccinated
if if i told you 10 years ago this isn't
about you in about 10 years in 2021
a guy's gonna come out with named tony
okay
who's in his 80s who's going to say
we have to mandate vaccine if i told you
20 years ago nicki minaj decides to not
go to an award ceremony
because she says a one of her friends
from trinidad one of her relatives in
trinidad got a vaccine and you know
afterwards they couldn't have a kid
because something happened and anyways
she says that she says i'm worried i'm
doing my research but i'm getting closer
to feeling confident to take the vaccine
i'm willing to do my own research and
she decides not to go to awards ceremony
because they wanted people to be mad
vaccinated then a lady from cnn cnbc i
don't know which one it was msnbc she
says you have a lot of followers it's a
shame you have 22 million followers i
have 2 million followers shame on you
for using twitter to tell people that
you could have done something about this
yet people are dying if i told you 10
years ago how dare you be your own
person but if i told you 10 years ago
that the idea of choices
is going away would you have said that's
possible would you have said that's
going to happen to america the idea of
having a choice is yeah i see what
you're saying right there so that's the
whole point is having the option or
having the choice bro like the biggest
nobody likes mandates
let me ask you a question but at the
same time you can't just say
i have the choice to run the red light i
do what i want it's like no there's laws
but you do have the choice right exactly
i mean then you go to jail or your car
story my life i have no choice though
i'll pay the ticket
it's a story in my life my license got
suspended twice so it's my choice that's
fine right i have a choice
certain areas yes but for me to have to
put something in my body that's not my
choice i'm with you you should have the
choice yes here's the other part
medicine you know
yes i'm talking to a guy named michael
shermer i don't know if you know who
michael shermer is michael sherman's got
a he wrote that book said uh weird
things what's the book called something
about weird things anyways very
interesting guy he went from being a
christian to being an atheist to being
an agnostic okay the guy's got uh great
ideas on what he talks but he pushes
everything back christianity we had a
very strong debate yesterday he says you
know what's crazy he says for about a
year and a half you couldn't question
the fact that the kovit may have come
from china until it took a comedian to
go on stephen colbert to talk about it
where the world finally said johnson we
can talk about it you john says how's
that even possible so freedom of speech
in the last 24 months very weird choice
very weird these are real fundamental
stuff that makes america great
these are the things that have changed
and uh there's a part of it where you're
worried whether people are willing to
fight back or just sit there because
at the end of the day what's the first
thing people think think about how do
they make their decisions they make
their decisions with what what's their
best for their family or themselves
right typically what's in it for them so
why do you think this whole idea of tax
the rich is so popular because ninety
percent of the country is not rich
so they're like i don't give a [ __ ] go
rich go tax everybody right but 30 years
ago the whole idea was what man one day
i'd love to be what rich it was the
story of the life of the rich and famous
people aspired to it was like
let me go one day get this kind of a
lifestyle let me one day go to a party
like this dude wait today's the other
way do you think people really think 3.5
trillion dollars in taxes are about to
be levied against the the american
public and it's only going to be the
rich i got to call earlier seriously no
it's going to destroy everybody but a
small a small business that's making a
half a million dollars a year you saw
kudlow talk about it small business
that's making half a million dollars a
year
you know what it means to increase their
tax capital gains by the way they're
already talking about they're gonna back
data to yesterday
like this morning i was talking to uh
greg
they're talking about they can back date
capital gains to yesterday
top line taxes they're raising to 39.6
they're adding an additional three
percent for people that make over five
million a year and then on top of that
the small business taxes that's also
being risen uh by i think it's like six
and a half percent some number like that
six percent they're increasing it um but
this is just a proposal this is nowhere
near passing not it's no longer just the
proposal now it's getting to a point
that it could be passed before one one
the only thing that's it is for one joe
joe manchin is the only thing he's
literally the only person again he's
he's literally the only person that's
known so when you ask me about america a
lot has changed the last 20. people that
think that this is only going to be the
rich need to look at one thing all right
i sent you guys this last night biden
directed the treasury his treasury and
the irs
to start tracking all transactions for
bank accounts as low as 600
meaning if you put a hundred dollars in
to dogecoin and and it's 6x you've got
600.
no it's for everything but but it's also
tracking crypto for the first time you
put 100 into whatever to dogecoin you
hit the lotto 600 bucks you pulled it
out all right they're going to come at
you for 150 bucks you made hundred
dollar investment you 6x congratulations
kid you're you're an 18 year old they're
gonna want 150 dollars in taxes on that
and then back pay like they're they're
coming so people that think that this is
only you know a soak the rich type of a
situation bro they're tracking you down
to 600 years by the way listeners i got
a question for you
to you define rich what is rich to you
i'm curious
actually put a number to it okay like
you know how they say this person's tall
what would you say is tall
what height would you say is tall
depends on where you are but playing
ball like really um what's tall in
america well this is the thing so you
know when hillary clinton was coming out
with this whole if you're uh a dual
family yeah in america and you make a
combined
100 000 you're wealthy this was like
eight years ago i remember being i was
playing ball in iowa at the time and i
was like you know what a hundred
thousand dollars in highway you're
pretty rich hundred thousand dollars in
in north jersey you're just paying the
bills what would you say is tall what's
tall on the market i get what you're
saying is that there's no exact answer
is there is there is six feet left and
you could say ten is tall i think six is
tall i don't think six is tall i think
six quarters is above 510 is the average
mills height in america five nine five
ten five nine five okay six is tall i'd
say anything over six three is tall i
don't i think you're six that's what
you're saying because you are six i
think six is tall but but here's the
thing what is rich i'm actually curious
what people say here uh a million
dollars is rich ten million dollars is
rich five million dollars is rich
hundred million dollars at least daniel
says 10 million in assets over a million
dollars says
valeria uh uh uh over a million dollars
okay augustine says five million dollars
so if you have a million dollars what is
that that's 50 000 a year for 20 years
that that's what you're but here's the
point though corey mcdonald mcdougall
says three hundred thousand dollars
ethan eats says thirty five thousand
dollars ricky aguirre says five hundred
thousand dollars yeah
no not ricky aguilar ricky aguirre ricky
aguirre says 500 000
here's the point who the hell decides
what's rich right okay because to me
aoc when i was working at bally's aoc is
rich
are you kidding me because when i worked
at valleys the guy i was looking up to
was a guy named robbie solomon
he had been at valleys for nearly 20
years he was an area supervisor
something everyone aspired to be guess
what he was making
150 year after 20 years and the pitch
was patrick one day you can be an area
supervisor
one day you came in every supervisor
making 150 a year and i'm sitting i'm
like wow 150 freaking a year are you
kidding me this is insane if i make that
kind of money because i was making 36.
right 150 is a lot of money but you know
what it is when you make 150 it ain't a
lot of money so what is rich and who
defines what's rich
global scale everybody in america is not
everybody in america is rich right
global scale but but the challenge with
that is a politician dictates what's
rich a politician dictates like upon to
me the average person i'm sorry nancy
pelosi is super rich elizabeth warren
rich
you got
bernie sanders super rich you got a aoc
rich you got a lot of people that are
rich so who dictates what that number is
is it like you know how you said you're
six feet i think six two is tall
it's the same exact concept right it's
what they say exact answer no no no it's
always more than what you have that's
the problem you just nailed it what you
did is what they do with taxes it's
always a little bit more than what you
are you natural i ask you what's tall
you said what six two i don't think six
is telling what are you talking about
guys like five nine and a half five ten
and you say what no i think six two
stars said no six is tall right to them
they say no oh
elizabeth warren i'm worth five million
dollars twenty million dollars is rich
then nancy pelosi makes a phone call to
elizabeth warren hey uh listen tomorrow
you can from 20 million dollars i'm like
i'm worth 50. why don't we do 75. 75
million
what the hell is rich anything above you
is rich you make 2 million 5 million is
rich so this is a bunch of [ __ ] with
this whole concept of tax on the rich
anything above them that they don't have
to pay the price let's tax those guys
that's a really good point you don't run
a business you don't you're not affected
by capital gains screw the guys that get
capital gains affect those guys you're
not affected by running a business
hiring people raising the minimum wage
who gives a [ __ ] raise minimum wage it's
okay we're not affected by it
let's raise a federal minimum wage to 15
bucks in dc 15 bucks is nothing but in
iowa 15 bucks minimum wage is a lot of
money that small business owner got
crushed by walmart that's the stuff that
a lot of everything you're saying
it can be
applied to any topic the money thing uh
abortion
taxes you're talking about schools
uh guns
the bible everything as long as it's
what they're doing and it's not me it's
it doesn't affect me
like
what's going on in texas right now with
abortions oh no you shouldn't be able to
have abortion six weeks it's like well
what happened to the lady that was raped
by her uncle and just incest in texas
and she found out you know two months
after
she she has no say in this so it's
always something that doesn't happen to
you and something happens to everybody
what is that called well you guys are
what is that what you guys are
discussing is the very basis of my
worldview why
why i believe the way i believe right
and i'm a libertarian most of the way
except i don't believe in the
non-aggression principle right but
there is no way
there is no way to centralize
government there's no way to take every
single aspect of our society and filter
it through the minds of these geniuses
which is what we're experiencing is is
an educational narcissism the likes of
which we've never seen we have an entire
system of people who went to school and
then they went to college and then they
went to law school and then they became
lawyers and then they got elected and
they they're in this cycle can you pull
up abortion what percentage of abortions
are rape
so they got they get into this cycle
where everybody throughout their whole
life has told them they're smart and
they're special so now they think that
they're so smart and so special that no
matter how many times centralization has
failed they're going to be the ones that
figured it out they're going to be the
ones that get it right this time i don't
believe that they can i think there's
too many variables at play so what i
believe in is
you do you and i'll do me do no harm if
it doesn't affect me you're welcome to
do it if you think that there is a real
problem with income inequality in the
world help the poor don't steal from
your neighbor and then give somebody
else money oh by the way take a couple
bucks for yourself for the effort right
and say that you're doing something
virtuous you're not virtuous at that
point right so
anybody who wants to do anything i'm the
biggest advocate for charity i'm the
biggest advocate for for volunteerism
anything that you want to do advocate
for it but stop short of mandating it
stop short of making it a law
libertarian that's it yeah here look
look at this usa today just one percent
of women obtain an abortion because they
became pregnant through rape but less
than half a percent do because of incest
according to the gut okay institute yet
the battle over exceptions for both has
garnered outside the attention national
abortion debate interesting so one
percent is
rape a half a percent is incest so
uh in the topic of rape you kind of
brought that up so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]